PROFESSOR: Uncertainty.
When you talk about random
variables, random variable Q,
we've said that it has
values Q1 up to, say, Qn,
and probabilities
P1 up to Pn, we
speak of a standard
deviation, delta Q,
as the uncertainty,
the standard deviation.
And how is that standard
deviation defined?
Well you begin by
making sure you
know what is the
expectation value of the--
or the average value of
this random variable,
which was defined, last
time, I think I put braces,
but bar is kind
of nice sometimes
too, at least for
random variables,
and it's the sum of
the Pi times the Qi.
The uncertainty is also
some expectation value.
And expectation
value of deviation.
So the uncertainty squared
is the expectation value,
sum over i, of deviations of the
random variable from the mean.
So you calculate
the expected value
of the difference of your random
variable and the mean squared,
and that is the square of
the standard deviation.
Now this is the definition.
And it's a very nice
definition because it
makes a few things clear.
For example, the left hand
side is delta Q squared, which
means it's a positive number.
And the right hand side
is also a positive number,
because you have probabilities
times differences of quantities
squared.
So this is all greater
and equal to zero.
And moreover, you can
actually say the following.
If the uncertainty, or the
standard deviation, is zero,
the random variable
is not that random.
Because if this whole thing
is 0, this delta squared,
delta Q squared must be
0 and this must be 0.
But each term here is positive.
So each term must be 0,
because of any one of them
was not equal to zero, you would
get a non-zero contribution.
So any possible Qi that must
have a Pi different from 0
must be equal to Qbar.
So if delta cubed
is equal to 0, Qi
is equal to Q as
not random anymore.
OK, now we can simplify
this expression.
Do the following.
By simplifying, I mean
expand the right-hand side.
So sum over i, Pi Qi
squared, minus 2 sum over i,
Pi Qi Q bar plus sum
over i, Pi Q bar squared.
This kind of thing
shows up all the time,
shows up in quantum mechanic as
well, as we'll see in a second.
And you need to be able
to see what's happenening.
Here, you're having
the expectation value
of Qi squared.
That's the definition of
a bar of some variable,
you'd multiply with variable
by the exponent of [INAUDIBLE].
What is this?
This a little more funny.
First, you should know
that Q bar is a number,
so it can go out.
So it's minus 2 Q bar.
And then all that is left is
this, but that's another Q bar.
So it's another Q bar.
And here, you take this one
out because it's a number,
and the sum of the
probabilities is 1,
so it's Q bar squared as well.
And it always comes out
that way, this minus 2
Q bar squared plus
Q bar squared.
So at the end, Delta Q, it's
another famous property,
is the mean of the square
minus the square of the mean.
And from this, since this
is greater or equal than 0,
you always conclude that
the mean of the square
is always bigger than the--
maybe I shouldn't
have the i here,
I think it's a random
variable Q squared.
So the mean, the square of
this is greater or equal
than Q bar squared.
OK.
Well, what happens
in quantum mechanics,
let give you the definition and
a couple of ways of writing it.
So here comes the definition.
It's inspired by this thing.
So in quantum mechanics,
permission operator Q
will define the uncertainty
of Q in the state,
Psi O squared as the
expectation value
of Q squared minus the
expectation value of Q squared.
Those are things that you
know in quantum mechanics,
how you're supposed to compute.
Because you know what
an expectation value
is in any state Psi.
You so Psi star,
the operator, Psi.
And here you do this
thing, so it's all clear.
So it's a perfectly
good definition.
Maybe it doesn't give
you too much insight yet,
but let me say two
things, and we'll leave
them to complete for next time.
Which is claim one, one,
that Delta Q squared
Psi can be written
as the expectation
value of Q minus absolute
expectation value of Q squared.
Like that.
Look.
It looks funny, and
we'll elaborate this,
but the first claim is that
this is a possible re-writing.
You can write this uncertainty
as a single expectation value.
This is the analog of this
equation in quantum mechanics.
Claim two is another re-writing.
Delta Q squared on Psi
can be re-written as this.
That's an integral.
Q minus Q and Psi.
Look at that.
You act on Psi with the
operator, Q, and multiplication
by the expectation value
of Q. This is an operator,
this is a number
multiplied by Psi.
You can add to this on
the [? wave ?] function,
you can square it,
and then integrate.
And that is also
the uncertainty.
We'll show these
two things next time
and show one more thing that
the uncertainty vanishes
if and only if the state
is an ideal state of Q.
So If the state that
you are looking for
is an ideal state of Q,
you have no uncertainty.
And if you have no
uncertainty, the state
must be an ideal state
of Q. So those all things
will come from this planes, that
we'll elaborate on next time.